This video is an ad for Dragonvale.
I gotta call Mark!
*Bob nearly lost  control of his phone to call Mark*
*Ring ring*
Hel--
*Bob* Mark!  Finally!
Dude! I have found it! The BEST mobile app ever! Seriously dude!  I--
No! Wait, shut up! I've already found a better one!
You're gonna love this, and I'm glad you called, because I need you to send me gifts.
Oh.  Yeah, okay.  Really?
*Bob's phone rings*
Bob!  Bob.  Hey!  Bob.  I need gifts.
Uhh, not-not real gifts, but in-in-game gif-- It's a--it's an app I found.
Pl-please?
Wade.
I am in the middle of something with Mark here, okay?
Hi, Wade...
Oh, Mark!  Good.  I need your help too.  Uh, I need you to be my friend.  Just this once...
*Wade* Uh, I need you both to play this app...and send me gifts...help me out...please?
Please?
Wade, no.  Wade, I'm not joining whatever crap game you're playing.
If you want gifts, you need to play Dragonvale, with me.
*Bob* You too, Mark!  Come on!
Alright, listen up you guys.  I need you to shut your collective faceholes right now, and listen.
I've got this great game called Dragonvale, and I need you to download it, right now.
No, lis--
No!  No!  No!  I'm tired of being interrupted!
Just get the game, be my friend, and give me gifts!
*Mark* That's what friendship is all about anyway!
(sigh) Mark...
*Mark* So, just fall in line, and if you don't, I will shove my funny foot...
up your mother-loving behind, you crazy boys!
...mahh.
Alright.  Thank you.  Love you.  Thank-love-thank you.  Love you.
Alright.  *smooch*  Love you, bye.
Hello, everybody!  My name is Markiplier, and welcome to Dragonvale.
Now, this video was supposed to come out before the charity livestream that we just did, and for good reason.
Bob and Wade's videos have already been posted, i'll put links to those in the descrption
and thanks to them, and them joining me on this paid promotion for Dragonvale.
I will be able to donate 10,000 dollars to 'Toys for Tots',
which is the charity which we've that we raise money for in this past event.
You can find the confirmation and proof of that donation
down in the description as well. So, this game, if you don't know about it,  it's kind of like a city building
game that you played on mobile before, probably. But it's different! You're trying to build
a dragon park. and your trying to breed and grow
dragons. And if you're wondering about breeding,
I'm absolutely 100% sure about that because
you get a place called a 'Breeding Cave',
and I'm not going to go into too many details about this cave
because frankly,
they don't go into too many details either.
It says, "This is the place where the magic happens.
*wink*
Seriously we're not sure how it works, we just know this is where dragons come from.
Upgrade the Breeding Cave decreases the amount of time it takes to breed
by 20%."
You know, they put in some scented candles, and some mood lighting
and some smooth jazz playing on in the background
for whatever magic is happening there.
And if that wasn't enough, there's an even better thing.
There's a cooperative breeding cave
And I don't know if there's info about this.
"The Cooperative Breeding Cave is a marvel of wizarding ingenuity
that allows two breeding caves to link their magic
Oh, working to cross space and time with the help of everybody in DragonVale,
the astronomer Noel... dePlante brought a piece of a falling star safely to rest.
He then did what any self respecting wizard would do with an unknown material -
he crafted a breeding cave.
Nogard says it's fine, as long as we don't destroy the universe.
You know,
I think it's fine too.
I'm, uh, I'm willing to allow this.
So I don't know how much of this is getting stuck in the game.
But I find this game hilarious and interesting nonetheless.
Okay! But that's for another time, we're gonna get back to that in just a bit,
but first we need to check in on our actual dragons,
which are adorable and cute and right here.
And, uh, this little guy
he's adorable, but the developers gave me
oodles and caboodles and umtoodles
of resources, so I'm gonna feed him until he grows up into a big-
-oh my god...
Oh no, you're marginally less cute!
Why can't you stay cute?!
Habity habity habity habity habity habity habity habity habity
*loud noise*
Oh
That's it?
Oh!
I guess Cinder's all grown up now, so we don't need to worry about that.
Oh shit! I leveled up!
Oh my god!
That's the thing about this game,
every time, you level up a lot
and every time you level up it unlocks, like, 15 bajillion things.
Which I guess is good
Oh my god!
What did I do?
I gotta-
What the hell?
Wait-
I got Celestial Habitat, Omnitat, First Galaxy Island, Fourth Galaxy Island,
Second Galaxy Island, Second Island, Third Galaxy- Oh my god!
Alright, Cinder, you go stomping around that volcano,
don't wreck up the place for anybody else.
Also you got these, winter-
it's the winter-themed version,
it's the Winter Jubilee,
which means there's a lot of winter-themed stuff.
And theres, uh, an abominable snowman walking around my-my farm
but I'm not sure what that's all about anyway.
Alright.
Hey, do you wanna-
Oh, I forgot I named this one 'Ballsacko'
Oh!
It's, uh, Ball-sa-co
It's not bad in any way
It's Ball-sa-co.
Alright, alright, Ballsacko,
Time to eat!
Oh, you're,
Oh god, you're way less cute.
Oh no.
Why do you have a ball above your head, Ballsacko?
That's not where your ball goes!
Oh boy!
Aura Habitat, Chrysalis Habitat, Large Cold Habitat,
Large Earth Habitat, Meridiem Habitat, Monolith Habitat,
Rainbow Habitat, Snowflake Habitat, Spooky Habitat
Twilight Tower, Weather Station, Blazing Gale Dragon,
Bog Dragon, Chrysalis Dragon, Decay Dragon, Delight Dragon,
Double Rainbow Dragon, Duskwing-
*high-pitched voice* Oh my god.
*high-pitched voice* Faire Dragon, Garden Dragon
*high-pitched voice* Icy Torrent Dragon, Ire Dragon, Icy Blossom Dragon, Lacewing-
*sped up high-pitched voice*
That's a lot of goober-
Oh my god!
Oh, fa-
Oh! I can just get the Fountain of Youth!
Oh, who knew?!
Who knew it was that simple?
Oh my god!
Breeding hints, hmm...
Do I need to know about this?
"The breeding pair of dragons must contain the andromedan dragon
and either a galaxy dragon or an epic dragon.
The breeding pair of-
Oh! These are the different types that I can breed.
Oh my-
How many are there?!
Oh my god!
*laughs* Oh my god!
There's so many!
Oh, there is so much stuff to this game!
That's kinda cool!
Rub'm Orbos *laughs*
You're gonna- You're gonna be Rub'm Orbos *laughs*
*giggly laugh* You're gonna be 'Rub'm Orb'
because that is as many-
That is- *laughs* That is as many, uhh..
That is as many characters as I'm allowed here and probably as much
freedom as I should have.
So now, let's breed 'em!
I mean, this is like the crux of the game
because to be able to get all the different variations of dragons, I imagine
that you have to breed them together.
So, I'm gonna get Rub'm Orbum
with Ballsacko,
Andddd...
Go for it!
Amazing!
*wizard voice* Amazing!
*wizard voice* I was peering in through the window and it was amazing!
*wizard voice* Magic happened! Don't know what it was,
*wizard voice* but whatever it was, it was amazing!
Oh ok.
Wait, they're- why are they above?
Why are they above the dragon cave?
That does- that doesn't make sense!
That's not the magic I was thinking about!
Alright, can I speed this along?
*mimicing in-game sound*
Breeder! I'm a breeder!
Yaaay!
Hey, if dragons were alive in real life,
I don't think I'd want to be a breeder of dragons.
That sounds like an incredibly dangerous occupation that which I do not want to be around.
Leave that to the Harry Potter worlds!
What?!
Hybrid Poison Dragon?!
*laughs* That's horrible!
That's horrible!
Put that in there...
Oh, no!
Why do you exist?!
Oh god no!
Ooh, what a specimen! Just, keep it at a distance, yes?
Oh god!
That's s- that's so sad!
It's so hideously ugly if we gonna keep it at a distance!
Ohh, ok. You know, wha- whatever.
I ain't gonna judge, who am I to judge?
Nope! Nope! Not anymore, handsome!
Nope! In fact, it's worse!
Ehh, it's much worse!
Oh boy!
Ohhh boy!
Oh god!
Why do you have a crown?
Oh, that's cool!
OOOOH!
So that's another thing about this game, there are a lot of minigames
and there's a lot of stuff that you can do, uhh, during the game.
Ok, that is all part of the Winter Jubilee, by the way.
So you're supposed to get iceberries and you're supposed to play these games
and get them for unique and excellent rewards.
And this is what you got. These are the minigames.
Oh god. I'm not gonna to be good at this, aren't I?
Hadoosh! Hapush! Habooski!
*mumbling*
*incoherent speech*
Oh shoot-y, shoot!
Oh, shoot!
Well, I sucked.
So anyway, that's the special event that's going on right now.
So I will leave this at that.
There's a lot more to explore about the game,
and, uhh, I've actually only scratched the surface of it.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Definitely check this game out, I'll put a link in the description.
And, also, you can check out the confirmation for the donation,
and Bob and Wade's associating videos down in the desciption below.
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And, as always, I will see you in the next video!
Buh-bye!